this book Li wrote her book in 2008 but
so ten years on here's the film she died
in 2014
am I being mean-spirited or was she
easier to deal with dead was not they
took me a year and a half to convince
her to write the book
she kept resisting it I said at least
it's a Vanity Fair article in this / New
Yorker article and they both rejected
and then saamana sister picked it up and
the book was done but it was difficult
then she was delighted that she got it
out of her system Melissa as as you read
the script I mean here's a woman who
pushed everybody away but you had to
make us want to get close to her how did
you pull that off well I think that's in
excellent writing and I think it's in a
true fascination I had with Lee I read
it and I did want to get closer to her I
wanted to know more I think you could
tell within her story and how Nicole
Hoff said I wrote her story that she was
isolating herself as a defense mechanism
and and she just was truly who she was
and I'm always I'm always incredibly
drawn to people that are in their own
shoes and don't feel the need to kind of
behave a certain way they just simply
are who they are even if it makes their
own life in a world more difficult and
I'm really attracted to that as a
character I want to play and I think
even in life I passed those people by
and I think well that's someone
fascinating because they don't care what
anybody thinks and how did you find the
script how did it come to you I my
husband
earlier several years earlier there was
a different version of this script with
other people in it I didn't end up
working out as happens all the time and
my husband was also in the first version
so when he brought home the script and
ice
Nichola HOF Center wrote it I just
wanted to read it cuz I was interested
into seeing what he was doing I thought
oh my god that's so good this
it's an incredible script she's
fascinating the whole thing and then
when it didn't happen I was kind of
crushed and I could never get Lee out of
my head so I just kind of kept asking
everyone so I was like what's that word
what's happening with that that movie
because somebody should do it it's she's
she's riveting I said somebody should
shine the light on that and I just kept
I just kept poking at it and then I
weaseled my way into Ben's movie Richard
I'm glad you wore your coat with the
velvet Chesterfield facings on it
because what struck me about your
performance was that it was almost
Dickensian that even though your
character was on the wrong side of the
law he had this macabre sense about him
that he was always going to come through
it was always going to make good some
how how did you nuance your character is
melissa new onsters I had no idea that I
was wearing Dickensian clothes here 2018
but I'm delighted that you think that a
little hint oh thank you how to answer
that I think that that everything is is
in the script and playing somebody that
is damaged as these people are is always
that's much more attractive and there's
much more meat to deal with as a
character and I think the other the
first movie director that I ever worked
with Bruce Robinson said that you in
order to play comedy you've got to play
it absolutely deadly seriously that if
anybody on the crew thinks that it's
funny it's going to be dead in the water
so I always remembered that and I
thought that was a great way into this
that they are people that are prickly
and difficult and porcupine like so
that's that's how I went in it and the
the Buddy movie thing that I watched was
avid I was so struck by the fact that
they have this platonic but very intense
relationship and the the one that
immediately came to mind was Midnight
Cowboy
the
that combination of Ritsu and Rizzo and
the jon voight character where people
who completely disparate have this
commonality so honestly New York to boot
exactly this is a script that is not
it's not a written as a comedy and so
the comedy in a way becomes Whittier
because of the contrast was that one of
the things that drew you to it and did
that make it easier to play or harder to
play um I don't think we were ever
reaching for any of the comedy I think
that I think Lee's wet and you know just
comes out through the stories and I
think Jack you know he was such a he's
such a bigger than life character for
these two very different people to find
each other and you know in a way it's a
love story that they just two very
lonely people that finally find someone
at least for a short time I think I you
just connect to that on a human level
but we were we were never concerned with
the humor of it I think when I saw it I
was surprised that people laughed as
much as they did but I thought oh that's
like it is her wit they you know it's in
there it's in the relationship but we
were you know doing so actors that
participated in Melissa so the
difference between the book and the
screenplay you have a more 360-degree
view of the character because when you
write about yourself obviously you're
not going to be able to convey that so
what what you saw in the screenplay and
then brought to the screen there there
was this synergy with Richard's
character too that you probably didn't
even find in the book I would think no I
think I mean luckily I think right when
we met and we didn't meet until what was
it Friday and then we were shooting on
Monday and we just kind of hit it off
immediately and I think we both and I
mean I was still I was so delighted how
he was playing it and I just thought oh
like what a what a whirl wouldn't coming
into her life and it just made
and if all those scenes so fun and I
think the synergy can also from Mari
just we all saw I think when you're
really seeing the same film and you see
the same people and then you know
there's latitudes and in and the ability
to stretch in different directions but I
think we were all seeing the same thing
and then you're actually able to just
get in there and and play the scene
pretty truthfully and it I think it made
it so much more fun sometimes I didn't
expect it or so much more heartbreaking
what role did New York play in the fact
that you know this is the kind of New
York that you don't see in a Woody Allen
movie necessarily it is more Midnight
Cowboy
I think the romance is really sucked out
of it a lot and there's there's I mean
from the moment that she wakes up and
there's the rotary dial princess phone
by her bed you think this is a very
different kind of New York I mean I was
in New York for those years that was so
to me I felt like I got back the New
York I fell in love with that was not
shined up and cleaned and pretty and we
were living pretty hard and it I don't
know to me there was a romance about it
of what I guess what could be and what
people were striving for and and to see
her and Jack kind of just so so in such
solitude moving through such a big city
you see New York and it's always this
you know everyone's gonna welcome you
and and it's I thought it was very
interesting to just look at New York and
individuals moving through it that are
somewhat invisible and to tell their
story and and I loved it for that but I
thought New York is a huge character in
this and all the book shops were
authentic and many of them were the book
shops where Lee operated are they still
there you know what happens to book
shops anymore yeah with Mary told us
that during the location scouting many
were closing down and so I don't know
whether they've subsequently more have
closed down but all of the books there
were no sets they're all real book shops
David this is absolutely what you wanted
for the authenticity and also I suppose
then it was all realized perfectly I
mean
welcome back to next stop Greenwich
Village which was at that bear Paul
Mazursky is great movie it's it's an
authentic as you can get the gritty
stuff and hope you know that are
creative I think we felt that in this
film on the Judas bar as well
the oldest gay bond in Manhattan and you
know that's where she lived and operated
yeah everyone seems to want to know
about the cat was the cat discovered in
Julius bär cat was impossible no I'm
kidding
they got a cat have its own trailer the
cat should have the cat kind of was
killing it like a cat was really good in
there in the scene with the in the vet's
office when it was supposed to be sick
and I literally said something like look
at it it's not doing well it sneezed
which it was not trained to do and then
literally was like and I thought oh my
god I'm getting out acted by cat I gotta
like I gotta up my game like it was kind
of amazing like when the cat there
really quit you know you can't really
the cat's gonna walk towards food when
you open a can of cat food the cats
gonna go towards it and then they'll be
a trainer doing all this stuff off
camera and it was like oh don't eat the
food the Kant was like got it like would
ignore us when it was supposed to it was
kind of crazy like at one point I'm like
is the cat animatronic because I'm not
buying it it's a delight please thank
our panel